charter school is breaking ground today  cactus park elementary will focus on the  mental and emotional wellness of  students the school feature both inside  and outside classrooms along with a  campus farm that will have chickens and  goats school will also have a cactus  park with 10 different types of cacti  students and teachers alike will have  the opportunity for mental health kind  of wrap around services and what i mean  by that is  the way in which we have fun the way in  which we teach the way we staff all of  these things have that mental health and  social identity kind of baked in to make  sure that our students lived experiences  don't have to stay at home  while the school is accepting  registration enrollment is free and  it's going to be open in august